[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radio Francia internacional
ponemos el foco en el mundial de fútbol
de Qatar 2000 de 22 sin duda el más
polémico de la historia vamos a analizar
tanto la parte política como la parte
deportiva con nuestros invitados syndi
colmenares periodista y cronista de la
emisora rtl bienvenida Cindy buenos días
a todos Ana María ospina compañera de la
redacción de refi experto en deportes
bienvenida
y Miguel Martínez periodista en la radio
televisión pública mexicana bienvenido
Miguel Muchas gracias
Qatar 2022 el Mundial de la polémica hoy
en Primera Plana
[Música]
el de Qatar es un mundial cuanto menos
distinto en el que se habla más de
política derechos humanos y boicot que
de tácticas deportivas por primera vez
en la historia del torneo las fechas se
mueven para evitar las altas
temperaturas y el mundial arrancará el
domingo 20 de noviembre con el partido
inaugural entre Qatar y Ecuador muchos
aficionados se plantean estos días la
conveniencia de boicotear la cita
deportiva debido a varios factores entre
los que se encuentran el número de
muertos en las obras de las
infraestructuras para el torneo
difícilmente cuantificables Más allá de
las múltiples polémicas el mundial de
Qatar será una ocasión única para los
fans de oriente medio de vivir el evento
cerca de su casa repasemos algunas
portadas el humanité titula zona de
obras mortal En referencia a sus
trabajadores que se han dejado la vida
construyendo los estadios la revista
Time también habla de juego peligroso en
esta portada y avisa de que en un mundo
sobrecalentado este solo el principio
algunos medios como el cotidiano la
reunión llaman Incluso el boicot con
portadas como esta sin nosotros en
nombre de nuestros valores llamamos al
boicot Bueno catar 2022 un mundial
particular por muchas causas empiezo por
lanzarles a los tres la misma pregunta
entienden que hay razones para llamar al
boicot de esta cita deportiva Cindy ahí
por un lado las personas los fans que
van evidentemente sienten dolor por la
situación de los trabajadores en Qatar
Pero por otro lado está la parte
política y la manera en la que se han
recuperado estos temas Claro que hay una
situación muy grave en Qatar como
también la hubo en el 2018 en Rusia que
es lo que estamos viendo el día de hoy
pero que ya se conocía Y en Argentina
también en otra época cuando hubo el
mundial bajo la dictadura Entonces yo
creo que es una oportunidad perfecta
para poner el foco sobre estos temas de
los cuales no se habla sino hay un
mundial Y esto es lo lamentable Ana sí
que haya razones y bastantes que es el
momento puede que sea tarde no lo creo
incluso durante el Mundial lo veremos 64
partidos 64 vitrinas para comentar lo
que sucede en Qatar Y gracias al mundial
vamos a poder conocerlo Miguel hay
razones y también yo creo que puede ser
el inicio también de Bueno creo que
mundial uno y un evento de este tipo
permite ver justamente todo lo que está
sucediendo en cada país y estas razones
Si hay razones y yo creo que también
puede haber lo decía hace rato para los
próximos mundiales también que no va a
ser muy fácil Tampoco porque ahora van a
ser tres tres países Próximamente
primero Qatar la polémica está lanzada y
después vendrá bueno el mundial 2028
Canadá México y Estados Unidos y también
se pueden cuestionar ciertas cosas no
Qatar en este caso ha sido objeto de
numerosas críticas de organizaciones
humanitarias a propósito de los derechos
de trabajadores extranjeros llegados
sobre todo de África y el sudeste
asiático para construir sus estadios
amnistía internacional ha reclamado un
de compensación de 420 millones de euros
destinado a los miles de inmigrantes
cuyos derechos no han sido respetados
durante las obras
Qatar se defiende diciendo que ha hecho
múltiples reformas no sé si podemos
decir que evolucionado el modelo laboral
pero también hay otro tema cuando el
foco ya no esté ahí que va a pasar es
justamente lo importante nuestras
responsabilidades de todos si no estamos
haciendo el boicot de Qatar es también
asegurarnos que hayan verdaderos cambios
mientras estemos en el Qatar y que el
mundial tenga lugar en ese país es muy
triste y es lo complicado luego poder
ayudarles porque cuando ya los países
generalmente se retiran cuando el evento
se va esto queda de esa manera sucedió
en Brasil sucede también en América
Latina y en otros países y es lo lo
lamentable para muchos la atribuciones
en sí misma del mundial de Qatar fue un
error ya de primeras digamos en origen
noana y muchos señalan la
responsabilidad precisamente que tuvo
Francia y en concreto presidentes
sarkozy Qué hay de cierto en todo ello
la primera vez que escucho hablar sobre
el tema fue en 2013 por la revista
han hecho eco pero en ese año
en el hélice o en talentos especiales de
Nicolás sarkozy Michelle platini
presidente de la UEFA con él Entonces
príncipe del catar Hoy es el Emir Bueno
es un hombre complicado va a tratar de
decirlo a Madrid halifa altaine hoy de
Qatar y del que entonces era dueño del
París saint-germain capital Sebastián
que era su representante bueno se cree
que ahí donde se dio esa idea de por qué
no buscar la forma que el Qatar le fuera
atribuido ese mundial y en contrapartida
una serie de posibilidades entre ellas
la compra por parte de los cataris del
París saint-germain lo que se dio un año
después eso coincidió con 10 días antes
del voto de la elección eso es un tema
que está abierto en Francia Todavía no
se ha dado una decisión definitiva pero
recordar que hace dos años Estados
Unidos habló y condenó a tres
funcionarios de la FIFA por corrupción
en el caso de la atribución de la copa
del mundo lo que está claro y demostrado
son los intereses que los diferentes
presentes franceses han tenido con Qatar
y los intereses económicos de Qatar aquí
en Francia No sí Bueno también este no
olvidemos que el que
para la explotación petrolera Eso quiere
decir que tenía un económicamente como
postular a la FIFA de pronto ganarle a
Estados Unidos que era su principal
contrincante y además poder construir
todas las infraestructuras que se
necesitaron
como un elemento del llamado Software
que ejerce Qatar en el mundo no Miguel
Sí sí yo creo
regresaron sobre el tema de que hablamos
de las reformas por los trabajadores y
todo eso También hay que recordar que es
cierto que hay problemas hacia los
trabajadores los derechos de los
trabajadores Pero bueno hay que recordar
también que en Francia actualmente hay
un proceso contra dos empresas
constructoras que están involucradas en
la construcción de diversas
infraestructuras para el mundial
entonces hay una complicidad cierto no
hay que esconderlo lo que está
sucediendo en Qatar pero también hay una
una complicidad detrás de las grandes
potencias todo los representantes de la
FIFA que ahora plata venga a decir que
fue un error no a mí me parece que él
forma parte de este círculo de
corrupción que había para la atribución
del mundial vamos a seguir añadiendo
polémicas porque esto se suma el respeto
de los derechos de las minorías por
ejemplo
lgtb en Qatar los derechos de las
mujeres no se creen que vamos a asistir
algún tipo de Raven y reivindicación
durante estos días porque también
aparecen también elementos como llamados
de la FIFA concentrarnos en el fútbol lo
cual no sé si quiere Eso quiere decir
que que evitemos la parte política no no
sé cómo ven este tipo de llamamientos
sé que sea exponiendo camisetas con
mensajes y la bandera
no sé Cómo interpretar la palabra
prudencia en este contexto no yo creo
que es muy importante al contrario claro
se respeta el país donde va a anfitrión
pero también hacer la gente sigue siendo
libre los jugadores son libres y poder
hacer algunos gestos pero el problema es
respecto Por ejemplo si tomamos El
ejemplo de Francia por un lado no
podemos decir boicote alcatarse al mismo
tiempo Tenemos tantos hoteles si usted
va a la avenida de los campos elíseos
John felices en París mucho de esa
Avenida es catar quien es propietario
tenemos al París Saint Germain en
Hidalgo que es la alcaldesa de París
ella no quiere que hayan grandes
pantallas en las fansón por ejemplo en
París no va a haber panzón no va a haber
pantallas pero al mismo tiempo tiene
está muy contenta que sea el Qatar que
es el propietario del París
que descubrimos estos días
nombró también la Torre Eiffel cuando
llegó Neymar entonces ahí está muy
contentos y al mismo tiempo ahora hay
algo político que molesta pero es porque
está el foco sobre
el mundial ya fue concebido hace
muchísimos años y parece que ahora todos
estos movimientos es porque está el foco
ahí No claro es importante recordarle a
la gente que nos escucha y que nos ve
que catar es un emirato es heredado es
una monarquía por lo tanto tiene leyes
propias que lo contienen un país que es
independiente Desde 1971 allí son
ultraconservadores Entonces está
prohibido maldecir beber y entre ellos
las relaciones con personas del mismo
sexo que tiene que ver con tu pregunta
cuál sería el llamado la FIFA pide
prudencia en el sentido de el fútbol o
político lo cual es imposible porque el
fútbol es política pero hace le pide más
a todos a los jugadores que se dediquen
pues hacer su trabajo cierto que es
jugar al fútbol este jueves se conoció
que Dinamarca que había solicitado la
permisión de tener una camiseta especial
por los derechos humanos de forma
general con mensajes pues se le prohíbe
utilizarla para no enviar un mensaje
erróneo Pero insisto 64 partidos es
decir 64 ventanas para hablar de los
problemas que tiene Qatar y que tienen
otros Miguel Sí bueno lo de Dinamarca no
sé si quedó la playera de un solo color
no roja Entonces ya habla también de que
hay un se están lo político y lo
deportivo va a estar mezclado en este
mundial y no va Y eso va a ser un antes
y un después para acatar más cosas
insólitas cómo creen que pueden afectar
las fechas inéditas en las que se
disputa este mundial porque claro creen
que los jugadores pueden llegar por
ejemplo en un estado de forma mejor que
en el mes de julio cuando es habitual no
yo diría que sí
[Aplausos]
que es el jugador el atacante estrella
del equipo de Francia con otros que
llegan en condiciones físicas se están
preservando este tienen muchos match
vean el caso de esadio Mané que es la
estrella de senegal y que llega no puede
ir al mundial porque tiene está
lesionado entonces claro para mí este el
hecho ya desde hace mucho tiempo que los
jugadores de fútbol les tengan match de
manera defrenada porque el show tiene
que continuar pues es está afectando a
los jugadores y se reciente es un riesgo
Por supuesto porque hay más riesgos de
lesiones el caso de sabio Mané que
todavía no es seguro que no esté en el
mundial y de otros que se van a perder
esta cita pero qué sucede es más un
problema para los clubes porque tienen
que parar su temporada con miras a lo
que sigue liga campeones pero jugadores
llegan en su mejor forma Por qué Porque
damos El ejemplo de Neymar la forma como
está jugando el mismo mes y algo que no
veamos en años y tienen que llegar con
tantos partidos que ya llegan preparados
para el mundial
es mejor yo creo mejor y va a ayudar a
poder ver un buen espectáculo de fútbol
porque es Es un periodo de transición en
el fútbol siempre porque están
terminando estamos a media temporada en
el lado europeo Ya se acabaron la
primera fase de Liga de Campeones
entonces todo el mundo se está
preparando para la fase final y que los
jugadores vayan a tener un partidos con
su selecciones nacionales ahorita en
diciembre va a ser yo creo que va a
haber un alto nivel diferente a lo que
vemos en normalmente en verano les tengo
que preguntar por el favoritismo de
Brasil también por las otras elecciones
de América Latina por los europeos Pero
va a ser a vuelta de pausa hasta ahora
[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo
miles de personas cada año se ven
obligadas al Éxodo a huir de sus países
en busca de una vida mejor Llevamos una
mirada humana a la migración masiva en
América Latina y en el resto del mundo
[Música]
acompáñenme en migrantes por France 24 y
France 24.com
la historia de nuestro mundo está en
constante cambio el flujo de información
es cada vez mayor estamos ahí con todos
los temas nos comprometemos con la
verificación desde el terreno en todas
las circunstancias para anticipar el
futuro y entender el presente lo
acompañamos 24 horas 7 días a la semana
Franz 24 una mirada diferente a la
actualidad
seguimos en Primera Plana analizando el
mundial de fútbol de Qatar 2022 sin duda
el más polémico de la historia lo
hacemos con los periodistas indie
colmenares Ana María ospina y Miguel
Martínez antes de la pausa estamos
hablando claro de las dos partes que
tiene este Mundial de la polémica de la
política pero también de la deportiva y
como Cómo se van relacionando ambas
creen que vamos a hablar más de deporte
o de política Durante este mundial
mucho de deporte Pero es verdad que en
la en el preámbulo del mundial
generalmente se habla muchísimo deporte
y es una diferencia no se ha hablado
tanto de deportes se habla más del
contexto pero ya yo creo que cuando
entremos en el mundial y que empecemos a
ver la forma en la que se encuentra
Messi no se puede olvidar que es el
mundial el posiblemente el último
mundial de muchas grandes estrellas
Exacto Messi cabani Suárez o sea por
hablar de los suramericanos entre otros
Entonces es una generación una gran
generación de futbolistas que van a
disputar su último mundial no posible
escalón y lo quiere ver en el 2026 es lo
que lanza pero es posible que se pare en
este mundial entonces Bueno claro yo
creo que en algún momento vamos a
empezar Ya a hablar más de lleno de
fútbol más de político de fútbol una vez
que el balón empieza a rodar ya Vamos a
ponernos a hablar de deporte y no tanto
de todas las polémicas que arrastra este
mundial Ana insisto el fútbol es
política el deportes políticas
Seguiremos hablando de política y mejor
porque de eso se trata saber en qué
posición está el lugar que recibe una
cita orbital pero estamos esperando
también hablar de fútbol de favoritos de
los jugadores que se van de los
jugadores que llegan de las promesas el
fútbol es cada cuatro años el mundial es
el momento donde el mundo se paraliza
para ver el balón rodar que nos permite
aprender de geopolítica pero también de
deporte y los que no en fútbol de
costumbre Pues ahí van a estar en la
pantalla vamos a pasar a la parte
deportiva aunque como dice mi compañera
Ana quizá volvamos a la política porque
van los dos temas relacionados en este
caso empecemos por el favorito Brasil
gran favorito de la cita Miguel
Argentina Pero bueno tiene muy buena
generación Brasil a pesar de que
bueno para mí para mí Argentina es de lo
favorito y como decíamos Pues bueno es
su último mundial seguramente entonces
van a darlo todo eh Brasil Yo hoy día
más también por Argentina por Argentina
vemos lo vemos más seguido en el París
saint-germain alguna forma que no lo
hemos visto pero Argentina no se puede
olvidar que hicieron excelentes
eliminatorias con 13 durante sus
eliminatorias están en un estado genial
y pueden ser uno de Los favoritos son
ustedes los expertos yo he consultado he
leído y y veo que Brasil es el gran
Favorito pero pero vamos a ver usted
ustedes dirán bueno el equipo está muy
organizado tiene una gran nómina Neymar
insisto está haciendo una temporada
increíble con París saint-germain pienso
que va a ser una de las figuras de este
mundial como no lo habíamos empezado
favorito quiero decir que es un equipo
que va a brillar que tiene una nómina y
según las casas de apuestas bueno
estaría Brasil bélica España pienso
ahora que Portugal es un equipo al que
le podríamos apostar porque es el equipo
que tiene las líneas mucho más completas
en cada jugador que está llamando y
tendría uno de los jugadores que
seguramente será la sorpresa de este
mundial que sería nuno Méndez el mejor
lateral izquierdo en ese momento juegan
París saint-germain si juega así con el
mundial que hemos visto y con la nómina
que tiene Portugal seguramente podrán ir
muy lejos y después de Brasil Argentina
quizá venga todo ese pelotón de Naciones
europeas Quizás lideradas por Francia el
otro día de Sam's desvelaba la lista de
Francia Qué les parece la composición
entiende la polémica despertada también
por la convocatoria de Benzema
no yo creo que ya el tema
vamos
a la selección
hace
que pueda ganar una copa del mundo
también puede ser Francia Pero bueno
vamos a ver porque no han dado lo mejor
en los últimos partidos de preparación
Es verdad que cambió de sistema antes
jugaba con con tres Defensores ahora
está se vuelve al sistema de cuatro
Defensores que no funcionó muy bien
durante la Eurocopa pero que es el que
tienen hábito y también yo creo que es
por las ausencias tiene algunas
ausencias de jugadores importantes
el mediocampo no da mucha seguridad pero
tienen también jugadores muy buenos en
todos los en todos los niveles de todas
maneras yo pienso que para ganar este
mundial Francia en el 2018 también llegó
de manera no se sabía mucho llegó como
favorito y fíjense que al final gana el
mundial O sea que tiene los elementos
para poder ganar para llegar pero como
Holanda donde hay buenos jugadores en
cada línea buenos elementos
jóvenes de Van Gogh o sea son jugadores
también muy buenos que pueden crear una
sorpresa durante
las últimas citas
importantes futbolísticas
es más cuando Francia le gana a Bélgica
siendo uno de los equipos realmente más
completos para ganarse el mundial es
cuando los franceses en ese momento se
dicen podemos ser campeones del mundo y
llegar más tranquilos frente a Croacia
Así que sí va a ser un hueso duro de
Robert como se dice recordemos 32
equipos son los mejores del mundo
representación de América Latina Ecuador
Argentina Costa Rica México Uruguay y
además de Brasil como ven los combinados
latinos cómo lo ven Qué posibilidades
tienen bueno Argentina ya lo decíamos
hace rato pero también pero sí y bueno
Brasil pero es cierto regresar e
insistir en que bueno es el fin de una
era de los grandes jugadores yo creo que
también puede ser
ventana para para toda la juventud
pienso en algunos jugadores mexicanos
que apenas tienen 18 19 años que yo creo
que puede ser el inicio de una nueva era
para para otros jugadores y también de
Europa es muy difícil acabar con la
hegemonía europea por lo que sus ligas
implican cuatro mundiales seguidos
llevándose la Copa del Mundo Sí el nivel
no es el mismo todos llegan con la
ilusión de ganar es normal pero en el
caso de Ecuador por ejemplo que que va a
abrir el Val o esa fiesta mundialista
frente a Qatar hablamos hace poco con en
rfi con Jackson que es uno de los
defensores de un equipo francés de de
toda y nos explicaba Bueno vamos al
mundial con los ojos abiertos con la
esperanza de hacer algo Pero sabemos que
nos falta mucho a nivel deportivo para
ir a competir
el representación
Uruguay o sea son los últimos el último
mundial de repente de cavani con Suárez
o sea está ya una generación nueva más
joven que está lo va a reemplazar
entonces ahí también muchas ganas en ese
sentido y por ejemplo el jugador también
están las cosas un poco extrasportivas
no olviden que en esta selección hubo
algunas dudas con algún jugador Castillo
me refiero Donde había una duda si era
de Ecuador o no y otra vez Es como
siempre porque nació en Colombia
hay esas dudas y en verdad esto es
siempre Bueno un poco el folklore que
puede haber
alrededor de una copa del mundo pero que
también viene perturbar un poquito ese
tipo de equipos y no olvidemos que
Ecuador es el quien hable uno de los
partidos que abre el mundial O sea que
es una presión además suplementaria pero
yo creo que los en verdad las
oportunidades están para América Latina
en Brasil o Argentina Bueno antes les
decía Brasil favorito y bueno se han
revuelto contra mi teoría y ahora si
ahora Les propongo máximo goleador
quizás Harry kane de Inglaterra también
se van a revolver ya verdad llegar uno
de los mejores goleadores del mundo
actualmente es así que no se le puede
negar que tenga un equipo para ir a
marcar
No yo apostaría más por jugadores como
Neymar por ejemplo y el propio Benzema
mbappé claro
francés pueden pueden llegar a hacer un
gran goleador no políticamente correcto
pero iba a decir Bueno pero Neymar ahora
llega un poco desilusionado tras la
victoria de lulano
llegan horas bajas profesional iba a
separar algo
su apoyo a bolsonario de una forma pero
es verdad que el fútbol también
política con deportes que justo me ha
venido a la cabeza
y ciudadanos sí Y además son hinchas
atrás de Neymar y Neymar con esto esta
posición que tomó en Brasil es menos un
poquito menos popular ya bueno eso se
les olvidará de repente durante el
Mundial pero hubo en América Latina en
Brasil cantos que decían Neymar vas a
tener ahora que de por la fiscalidad O
sea que también claro un peso un peso
para él quién puede ser la revelación de
este mundial insisto nulo Méndez para mí
portugués 20 años lateral izquierdo del
París Saint Germain el mejor del mundo
actualmente para mí va a ser un jugador
que va a dar mucho hay que hablar
alguien más para apuntar Miguel Miguel
Brasil frente a lo mejor los vinicius
pero bueno son muchas son muy jóvenes
entonces hay mucha vamos a decir la
hegemonía está ahí pero abajo ahí hay
muchos jóvenes que que van a participar
con sus elecciones y que pueden dar la
sorpresa y bueno para mí yo creo que
alguien que pueda saltar como revelación
Argentina
a pesar de las preocupaciones éticas los
hinchas viajarán de forma masiva Qatar
es el caso de 70.000 mexicanos o 30.000
argentinos según Fuentes diplomáticas
bueno se van a encontrar con muchas
restricciones lo de la cantidad de
mexicanos que ver a caer sorprendente
organizaciones hablábamos si las cuentas
no me fallan creo que el aficionado
promedio mexicano
gasta muchísimo sigue compran los
paquetes de tres o cuatro partidos que
son los paquetes que se venden en la
FIFA y tienen un gasto promedio de 15 a
20 mil dólares por mundial cada
aficionado mexicano Entonces es un
es una inversión y y países y
América Latina lo no solo México pero
bueno de todos estos aficionados se
desviven por un mundial aficiones que se
van a encontrar con restricciones por
ejemplo con el alcohol
recordaba yo recordaba el mundial de de
Sudáfrica cuando se enfrentaron México y
Argentina como anécdota habían puesto
afuera del estadio en la cara habían
puesto carpas para los aficionados que
no podían entrar al estadio y habían
puesto carpas que de cada marca de
cervezas de corona y cenizas Entonces yo
creo que eso no va a ser posible en
Qatar no sé cómo están no he leído mucho
pero creo que eso no va a ser muy
posible poder estar viviendo en la calle
como ha sido en otros países en los
últimos tres mundiales el campeón que
defendía trono quedó eliminado En fase
de grupos es el caso en este caso Italia
España y Alemania lo sufrieron en
Sudáfrica 2010 Brasil 2014 y Rusia 2018
respectivamente Francia a la que amenaza
esta maldición en Qatar ya lo sufre en
2002 tras levantar el trofeo en 1998 que
vienen la maldición del ganador
no me parecería incluso mejor que en
estas condiciones y con esta maldición
que existe Francia pudiese avanzar hubo
una entrevista de mbappé en sport
industriaded que salió esta semana en la
cual dice que él ya ganó una vez y que
para él esto es el principio de una
historia que lo genial sería ganarla dos
veces seguidas y hay personajes en
Francia que son verdaderamente muy
ambiciosos jugadores como vape con
Benzema y yo creo que no ellos van a
estar a la altura de representa este
mundial
rollo me acuerdo en 2010 teníamos a Paul
el pulpo que decía quién ganaba los
partidos para darte un ejemplo hay más
una maldición que hablamos y a la
maldición de Pelé lo siento por el rey
Pelé pero cada vez que claro dice el
equipo que va a ganar ese equipo no gana
lo vimos en USA 94 con Colombia y pues
este año ha dicho que es Brasil
[Risas]
yo creo que bueno Francia tiene todo yo
creo que tiene También muchas
posibilidades hay que recordar Bueno
mbappé un gran jugador que está en el
París saint-germain pero también hay una
hay una ambición del Balón de Oro porque
estuvo fuera de la selección por
cuestiones jurídicas y bueno que ahora
regresa y le va a tocar un mundial
y en maldición usted no cree tampoco no
no pero les gusta nos gusta este
americano porque
de color un poco esto pero bueno Yo sí
que creo una maldición Muchísimas
gracias a los tres ha sido un placer
Seguiremos la parte política y la
deportiva de todo lo que nos traiga el
mundial el mundial de Qatar a partir del
próximo día 20 a todos ustedes les
esperamos aquí en Primera Plana la
próxima semana Muchas gracias
[Música]